first of all it's so good to see you
guys in person again
celebrating another season of the voice
we'll kick things off with miss camila
cabello the newest
[Applause]
camila that's the first clap i've gotten
from you
how's the new gig it's so fun i have so
much fun with these guys
i get excited and giddy when i see you
guys it's like going to school and
seeing your funny friends
your class clowns how have they
initiated you into the voice family they
hazed me
[Laughter]
fire extinguisher yeah
she did not see it coming the great
place you need someone is it every
season it's for you
no it's for we've never done it before
just for some something about her it
just brings it out it's a vulnerability
in me that they wanted to
hold her down yeah spit on her and all
that stuff
john when she was your team advisor you
said that she'd make a great coach i did
i told her that and who knew i was uh
charting my demise you know i was gonna
say are you shaking in your boots a
little bit now that she's got her own
she's such a great coach and she's gonna
be quite a formidable foe for us all
season but uh i knew she'd be a great
coach john got me this gig you got me
this guy i did not get you the gig but i
i said to you i was like you'd be very
good at this yeah and i was right she's
very good at it well we don't know yet
but now she's my enemy your voice is so
special it's getting hot in here if we
were on a dating app for the voice i
would swipe right
please help me you and gwen would make a
great team what the i want the best for
him no you don't you want the worst for
me vote can be true is she the one to
watch this season is camila everybody's
one to watch honestly everybody's got
really good uh team members and it's
going to be tough
and we remember that
yes likes losing this season
i was going to remind everybody that the
last time gwen was on she won
[Applause]
i'm a winner one time and i haven't won
since my first season and uh i feel like
i have to
go back and uh i'm a boy i have to come
back and win again give me like
camilla's killing i have i have at least
a couple people that i could see winning
the show me too i i feel the same for me
really yeah i do
okay we play politicians yeah
i mean we don't know it's so early in
the than the show it's hard to say but i
i definitely have a very cool artistic
team very cool well gwen welcome back
thank you i can't believe i'm back what
is your favorite thing about being back
um i mean being on set with blake is
just pretty fun like happy anywhere you
know what i'm saying
i could be happy anywhere with you
john you've always said too that gwen is
blake's weakness yes this is kryptonite
how romantic
are we seeing now
more competition or less competition
from mr shelton i think like i said she
uh takes the edge off him just a little
bit
um
and uh
she's his weakness
blake how do you feel
uh you know i i said earlier it's it's
it's not an edgy
tactic has always been because i get
attacked
by all three coaches it takes three the
reason you may not even know this
the reason there's four coaches on the
voice is because it takes three people
to go against me uh
everybody can say that about themselves
but
so i'm normally
you know mounting my defense against
three people but now she's in there and
so i kind of have to play you know right
it's it's
strategic did you feel more competitive
or less competitive how would you
categorize it more or less more
more competitive you gotta win for the
household yeah
that's a good way to look at it
you've been around since the very
beginning how would you say this season
all right
yeah he's the og he's the og he is the
other team
how would you say this season matches up
in terms of competition with the
contestants
uh well this competition is always
i don't know where these people come
from or why i i just don't know where
they come from
we have so many great singers in this
country yeah
it's unbelievable and every season just
amazing
and then like the the uh you know the
whatever our people are that don't make
it end up on the other singing
competition shows
and we always get the best of the best
you know that's that's where i wound up
yeah she somehow survived a disastrous
show
and she's also been a great i gotta say
in in and even she does this
mispronounces her own name
and i used to hear it over and over john
says it wrong when's it you say it
incorrect
correctly every time yeah i've said it
my name is kamilah
cabello
yeah yeah camelot is that yeah
[Laughter]
congratulations on another season
it's so good to have you back thank you
can't wait to see the antics that come
out it's gonna be fun
[Music]
you